forschende haben jetzt ein ganzes
verschollenes königreich der maya
aufgespürt schon seit ewigkeiten suchen
forschungsteams nach dem mysteriösen
königreich der maya mit dem namen sagt
sie
jetzt wurde es endlich gefunden die
ruinen von mehr als 120 bauwerken
verraten viele spannende details über
die rätselhafte kultur der maya über die
wir bislang kaum etwas wissen und das
königreich spielte wohl eine wichtige
rolle klick zum science fiction hier
gibt es täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's reichlich willkommen im jahr 1994
erfuhren fachleute zum ersten mal aus
inschriften dass eine gewisse meyer
stadt namens sagt sie existiert haben
muss doch dieses kleine königreich
konnte sage und schreibe bis zum jahr
2018 überhaupt nicht lokalisiert werden
doch auch skulpturen legt das ist dieses
königreich gegeben haben musste
2010 war es soweit und die ersten
grabungen konnten beginnen dabei war das
ganze ein echter glücksfall denn einem
archäologie studenten war zuvor eine
alte steintafel mit hieroglyphen
zugesteckt worden eine analyse
offenbarte dann dass es sich um eine
meyer schrift handelt und dass die tafel
aus dem lang gesuchten sagt sie stammen
musste mittlerweile sind die fachleute
fündig geworden 120 bauten konnten
bislang identifiziert werden darunter
auch mehrere tempel pyramiden einen
ballspielplatz einen marktplatz und
mehrere residenzen die inschriften auf
den so genannten stillen offenbaren dass
es sich tatsächlich um das königreich
sagt sie handelt gegründet wurde es um
750 vor christus und wurde dann wohl
mehr als 1000 jahre bewohnt und nicht
nur das die funde verraten viele details
zu der bislang noch unerforschten kultur
der maya
sie legen beispielsweise nahe dass diese
meyer statt über jahrhunderte hinweg der
sitz einer dynastie gewesen sein muss
die eine bedeutende rolle
in den zahlreichen machtkämpfen gespielt
hat und wohl auch politisch einen großen
einfluss gehabt haben muss dazu
schreiben den forschenden in ihrer
aktuellen studie der ort war eindeutig
der sitz einer dynastie mit größerem
einfluss als andere herrscher mit dem
abschnitt wie beispielsweise im wohnheim
pack oder lama
davon zeugt die zahl der am hof
stehenden
kulturen die arbeit die für den bau der
pyramiden und anderer zeremonieller
strukturen nötig war und die größe der
mehreren großen platz sass auch die
größe der stadt von mehr als 21 hektar
lässt darauf schließen dass es sich um
eine lagerstätte der mittleren größe
gehandelt haben muss die fachleute
konnten außerdem auch die reste einer
großen befestigungsmauer aufspüren das
leben bin sagt sie war offensichtlich
alles andere als friedlich das
königreich musste sich wohl häufiger mal
gegen angreifer verteidigen doch das
lief wohl nicht immer ganz glatt
inschriften verraten dass ein größerer
brand große teile der stadt zerstört
haben muss auch die bewohnerinnen und
bewohner von sagt sie waren nicht ohne
dazu heißt es in der aktuellen studie
sagt sie war ein beeindruckender vereint
und ein wichtiger verbündeter hat für
die größeren königreiche das zeigt sich
darin wie oft sagt sie in texten dieser
reiche vorkommt und genau das ist ein
weiteres bislang ungelöstes rätsel in
diesem kontext warum waren manche maja
königreiche so groß und hat einen enorm
viel macht und einfluss und warum
gelangen die es anderen maja
königreichen nicht fest steht jedenfalls
dass weitere erkenntnisse über sagt sie
dazu beitragen könnten dieses rätsel zu
lösen
dafür soll nun zeitnah weiter kartiert
und ausgegraben werden mythos aufgeklärt
rasanter untergang der maya-kultur
anklicken anschaut und abonnieren und
zwar wen wundert's diesen kanal klicks
um science-fiction hier gibt es die
spannende wissenschafts jungs bis dann
dran